hi i'm dr john anson i'm a neurosurgeon
working here at southern hills hospital
and this is showing you our
new augmented reality system for
spine surgery this system allows us to
actually
see the spine of a patient live during
surgery
it's like giving us x-ray vision it
starts with this headset
that has a heads-up display on it
so when i put the headset on i can look
through these
glass frames and actually
see the spine displayed on them even as
i look through
at the patient and at the instruments
that i'm using this array gets mounted
on the patient
and all of the instruments like this one
will have
another little array on them so i can
actually see
[Music]
exactly what i'm doing i'm showing the
computer
my instrument and what you're seeing on
the computer is what i'm seeing
in my up display so i can come in here
inside the patient's body so i don't
even need to make an incision
get to where i want to be
and get down right into the spine and
this is live in real time being able to
view
the actual anatomy as i'm doing surgery
we still do the same operations but it
allows us
to do them through much smaller
incisions and with
much more precise guidance
as to where we're going and what we're
doing it can be adapted to any variety
of instruments and
used up and down the spine we're the
first hospital in southern nevada to
have this technology
there's only a handful of hospitals
around the country in fact that have it
so i feel like we're really continuing
to be at the forefront of these new
technologies that allow us to do
better safer more precise and minimally
invasive surgery
i think it's going to help my patients a
lot i think it's going to make the
surgeries
better for them easier on them allow
better quicker easier recovery